hello and welcome to CEO Eric olia
corner like the London against this
anyway now I've played it have to live
with the consequences it leads a
super-solid yeah you cannot really be in
trouble with this opening okay okay
expected 94 didn't do that okay here d5
event that could be actually quite nice
for and for white it's the go night
before the night each it's no 92 it's a
bit slow maybe you can play some kind of
it is six opening up this I also
could've played 90 for him anyway we'll
see what happens e six there is not be
five so this is prolly not to grin no 15
okay let's play normal looking awesome
it has to be somewhat cautious here with
the pawns because of this 95 idea
it's not so easy still desert I can
let's see yeah so night be five what are
you doing
okay um so what's the deal and I'll take
him when I can take before take these
six which should win some stuff pong I
mean it can take be two anyway that's
not overthink things and go for it okay
where to take on e 80 / 119 yay dossier
it okay I'll grab yet and now I have one
upon which is good still how to how to
win how to play because it checked but
it's not the biggest deal ever if you
take that I just activate the Queen we
should be tool that will be one loop to
be six king position is safe that's nice
my idea is a quick rookie one trying to
play against it youporn ok so not sure
here not sure about this but ok I wanted
to play in a somewhat more active way so
Appy should be five this should be five
was a lot stronger ok
k
let's trade this
it moves the bishop away now I will just
take be 60 k can go look sorry we should
be four but any other move on take p6 I
guess whoa and this is just a technical
win right this is this yeah I've been
one of the pawns up to eight black
resigns it's no nothing dangerous yeah I
know it it was a bit bit of a strange
strange game year after this e5 move so
maybe I'm i had e5 haha ok 'if I've was
still ok for black hmm no keeps the pawn
something like this he has rupee six
looks kind of strange but well all these
pieces are somewhat in play so it cannot
be that brilliant for what I mean this
is not looking so great and some other
things and with this this should should
be ok I have 3s all that but thought
this is also good it winds up on
ultimate later and keep the position
actor if it takes here oops thanks here
that looks fine here should have played
bit should be five already so if cause a
lot better than be three I need to go to
e5 anyway so could have been a little
bit quicker and here after the bishop
trades the position is excellent yeah
I'm pulling up and he's got this bad
structure yeah this was immediately
dropping a second poem but the position
was already very very bad okay well
thanks for watching